Nenita Samba Llewyn is desperate she has
lost her home her farm and was forced to
move to this evacuation center with her
family when the earthquake struck North
Cobb at a province my children's feature
is destroyed
we've lost our home look at our
situation here now this is all what we
managed to save my daughter and
granddaughter are sick almost 20,000
people have been displaced since a
series of earthquake struck many areas
of the southern mindanao region last
month there are over a thousand families
in this evacuation alone and the
situation is similar all across north of
about the province they have been
displaced for days now and the situation
is dire the short supply of water and
food is running out these people are
keen to hear about their village and
whether they can return and retrieve any
belongings but they're told not yet so
for now this evacuation center will have
to do in the town of makélelé
the situation is worse aid is harder to
come by and many people are hungry
homeless and traumatized like heigen aya
a single mother of six she tells us they
are lucky to be able to eat twice a day
I don't know where to begin we don't
have anything to eat no place to sleep
it is harder for my children parents
like heigen are keeping their children
close they say the actor sharks are
strong and they have to stay vigilant
today is all souls day and people
usually come to cemeteries to remember
the dead but not this year for many
there is no time to grieve because
they're too concerned about how to
survive jameelah Linda and Al Jazeera
North Cotabato province
chill Philippines